en la región de lugansk en el este de
ucrania las tropas del gobierno se
enfrentan a las fuerzas respaldadas por
rusia mientras avanzan hacia el oeste
desde sus enclaves separatistas a un
lado de la carretera un tanque ha
variado arte
a medida que la invasión rusa entra en
su cuarto día la resistencia ucraniana
ha demostrado ser inesperadamente feroz
lejos de la capital sitiada las fuerzas
armadas siguen siendo viables y
continúan recibiendo armas y suministros
de los aliados occidentales
toda ucrania ha estado bajo una guerra
total y como resultado de la descarada
decisión del señor putin de enviar a sus
soldados a esta guerra sin sentido
injusta no provocará y totalmente
criminal tres mil quinientos hombres
rusos no volverán a casa
el gobierno ucraniano dice que las
fuerzas rusas volaron un importante
gasoducto en la ciudad nororiental de
harkov mientras que el gobernador
regional ha anunciado que las tropas
ucranianas estaban luchando contra el
ejército ruso que había entrado en el
centro de la ciudad
más al sur en la ciudad de micro los
civiles se unieron para apoyar la
resistencia
organizando donaciones y suministros
médicos y montando cócteles mólotov con
gasolina y poliestireno
al principio teníamos miedo mucho miedo
pero ahora estamos dispuestos a luchar
ya pelear como
muchos hombres y mujeres se registran
para tomar las armas de ellos mismos
aunque las fuerzas rusas siguen
superando en número y armamento las
ucranianas está claro que los invadidos
no van a caer sin luchar
[Aplausos]